okay so we've just been thinking about
transfer functions and especially the
loop transfer function essentially as
our control law followed by our plant or
our model of our system and I'm going to
demonstrate very quickly that you can
use this idea of a loop transfer
function to design a really really
effective control law at least for
simple plant dynamics okay so we're
going to go back to our trusty cruise
control example which is kind of
designed to look at uncertainty and
disturbance rejection and we're going to
look at our Augmented car model which
essentially has a little bit of dynamics
okay so it takes some time from when you
hit the gas to win the car speeds up and
if you take that differential equation
and find the transfer function the
transfer function for our system is 1
over s plus 1 okay so it's got a pole at
s equals minus 1 a stable pole on the
left half plane and what we're going to
do is essentially wrap feedback around
and have some controller that acts on
the error signal but this controller now
is going to have its own dynamics it's
going to be its own transfer function
which could be written as a differential
equation so remember when we were
thinking about the sensitivity and the
complimentary sensitivity and this loop
transfer function so I just want to
highlight this part here from epsilon 2y
is called our loop transfer function and
for good disturbance rejection and noise
attenuation and reference tracking we
want this loop transfer function to kind
of look like an integrator something
like 1 over F okay so if I was going to
plot the bode plot I would have we would
want the magnitude of this loop to look
like a simple integrator which is like K
over s ok a regular integrator would be
1 over s in the Laplace transform domain
here we're doing K over s so that we can
choose the crossover point the bandwidth
to be about Omega equals K ok so that
means this is going to have effective
reference tracking and disturbance
rejection for frequencies below K or you
know for these large when this is large
and it's going to have noise attenuation
properties for frequencies above K when
this is small so this is what we want we
want the loop transfer function to look
like K over s okay and so at least in
this really simple case now this is kind
of dangerous don't do this for all
systems without thinking about it but at
least for this stable system what we can
do is we can say well okay l equals so
it's P of U P K epsilon so it's P K and
I want this to equal sorry I should have
choosen a different number K I don't
mean K the transfer function I mean K a
number like 10 let's say this is 10 10
over my Laplace variable F then I want
PK to equal 10 over s okay and I know
what P is P is 1 over s plus 1 so I can
say well 1 over s plus 1 K equals 10
over s and so that means that K equals x
plus 1 times 10 over s now in general
this is kind of a bad idea so I want to
be I want you to have extreme caution
when you invert your plant like this
notice we literally divided by our plant
to solve for K that would make our
system look like this integrator loop
because we know that that has good
properties there are lots of times when
if I inverted this plant like if this
had a right half-plane pole then when I
inverted it I'd have a right half-plane
zero and essentially I would have an
unstable system and it would be
unobservable exactly where the system is
unstable so I'll talk about that later
but this can be very dangerous inverting
your plant willy-nilly don't do that
only like in a stable case I'm going to
use this for illustration but the idea
is I can shape what I want my to look
like I want to look like this 10 over
ten times an integrator and then there
is a que that gives me that desired loop
shape and if I use this as my controller
I should be able to get good system
performance now if my model was wrong if
P if my model for P was wrong then
hopefully feedback will help out but we
might get into into some trouble okay so
we're going to design the controller so
that this loop has good properties like
looking like an integrator but I want
you to know that sometimes this is very
non robust or even unstable and so
there's going to be we're going to have
to robusta fie this process we're going
to have to do some modifications later
to make this a little bit more robust
for lots of systems for the simple
cruise controller this is going to work
out just fine okay so let's pull up
MATLAB and try this out okay so I have
my my MATLAB system and here I'm going
to have the exact same car system that I
had before it's literally just a state
space model for the car for just P the
plant okay and what I'm going to first
of all do is I'm going to transform it
into a transfer function I'm going to go
from state space to a transfer function
now you can do it using this SS two TF
commands state space - transfer function
where I give it the a matrix B matrix C
matrix and D matrix and it gives me the
numerator and denominator and then I can
make a transfer function from that
numerator and denominator called
TF car you don't really have to do this
you can also define your Laplace
variable and just say TF car equals 1
over s plus 1 that's also totally fine
because we know the transfer function I
could have derived it from state space
using these commands or I could just
enter it as a transfer function
sometimes you will want to start with
state space and use the MATLAB commands
if it's a little bit messy but in this
case we could just write down the
transfer function okay and then remember
our desired loop this desired loop
function is 10 over s it's just you know
some big gain times an integrator so
that moves it up into the right it gives
us higher bandwidth performance and then
I'm going to
make this very naive kay where I just
take my desired loop divided by P
divided by my transfer function in my
car that's P okay and that's my
controller K gives my loop transfer
function this desired shape of an
integrator now again there will be lots
of plants where this is a really bad
idea and where you cannot with control
make your function look perfectly like
an integrator
but for now you know we'll talk about
those later we'll talk about how to
adjust this to make it more robust but
for now in this simple case we're just
going to invert our plant and get this
this integral leap transfer function
okay very simple to actually code this
up in MATLAB so I'm going to make
something called this loop which is just
the series of K followed by P K followed
by system car so that's my loop transfer
function and then my clothes loop system
is just my loop transfer function run
through the feedback command so I have
feedback 1 minus 1 that means it's plus
1 minus 1 around this loop okay and you
can look at the help commands to figure
out exactly how to use feedback in the
series for your problems series is
pretty simple it just change these
together and feedback just wraps
feedback around that loop okay and so
then the final thing we're going to do
is we're going to step our closed-loop
system to see you know I command a unit
of reference speed how fast is the
closed-loop system respond and I'm also
going to set my open-loop system where
I'm not doing any control at all ok so
I'm going to run these hopefully there's
no errors ok it's running and you can
see ok the open-loop is this red curve
that's kind of what we're used to seeing
where I just step you I'm not doing
anything fancy and it takes some time
for the dynamics to catch up but when I
tell my system I want you to be an
aggressive high-bandwidth integrator
loop function because I have good low
frequency performance good high
frequency performance then this blue
curve is that closed-loop controller so
I got this really really really steep
rise to steady state followed by nice
plateaued performance ok
now I'm not quite sure how this would
handle it if I had a little bit of model
uncertainty I actually haven't run this
before so let's say I develop my K based
on a model like this but let's say that
my car actually responds a little bit
more slowly let's say it's a minus 0.5 X
instead of minus 1 X so I'm going to say
ts car in actuality is 1 over s plus 0.5
ok so I built my controller based on a
model that was this but my actual car is
going to be 1 over s plus 0.5 it's not
going to be exactly what I think it
should be I hope this doesn't break it
might break because I told you this is a
bad idea sometimes so then I'm going to
take that same K developed from the
model I'm going to build the loop
transfer function with the actual car
model the real car dynamics and close
loop and let's see what that looks like
I'm going to actually end it here so I
don't plot the other stuff ok it's
running it's running it's running
interesting ok so it doesn't blow up
it's not unstable and it goes to a good
steady state value but it's a little bit
slower because the car dynamics are
slower because this is actually a
different transfer function than we
thought it was ok and in fact if I want
to look at what the actual system loop
is I can say bode of this loop ok and
I'm also going to say hold on and I'm
going to bode my desired loop ok well
there I think they're on top of each
other but anyway you see that the
desired loop function was this
integrator this is that's what an
integrator looks like in the in the
frequency domain and my actual system
loop is also an integrator ok
um okay good so that gives you a very
very rudimentary idea about how I can
use those ideas of designing the shape
of the loop transfer function to have a
certain behavior like I wanted to have
high gain at low frequencies so it
tracks references and rejects
disturbances I wanted to have low gain
at high frequencies so it attenuates
sensor noise and sometimes I can do that
by finding the K that makes P times K
look like you know some gain times an
integrator okay in lots of cases we're
going to have to robusta fie so in that
lab there's a command that essentially
takes this guess for K and then tweaks
it to make it a lot more robust so that
it's stable across over and it has all
these nice properties we'll talk about
that later but for now I want you to
realize how simple it is if you have a
model for your system you can
essentially develop your K instead of
through lqr and common filter I just say
hey I want my loop transfer function to
look like an integrator and that lab can
handle the rest okay
so we'll plug this into robust control
we'll do some more analysis of
sensitivity and complementary
sensitivity and we'll look at more
complicated examples but this is kind of
just a first step in that direction of
loop loop shaping okay all right thank
you